one of the things that this documentary
has really implanted in my brain is that
things take time
they take time to realize you're not in
a good situation they take time and one
of the problems is in the legal
situation is the statute of limitations
and that it's one to three years and in
california it was one to three years it
was
you you work so hard
on yourself
but then you work so hard for other
people
and you go and you start this journey of
legally trying to change the system
because you so eloquently explain
that it takes time for people to realize
that they've been a victim that they've
been gaslit to have the bravery you have
written now what is called the phoenix
act and you have changed legislation in
california
which is incredible
[Applause]
what was
the moment that you said i am willing to
do this
not just for myself but other people it
was when i found out there were other
people and this is the part that
actually
makes me the most emotional is when i
talk about
how desperately
people need help
when i first
started speaking about
my abuse
uh i was still sort of in the midst of
processing it when i testified in front
of congress for another bill for the
sexual assault survivor's bill of rights
i thought that was going to be it i
thought that was going to be the only
time i told my story i was going to
leave it there walk away move on and
then i i saw after i testified all these
stories popping up on the internet
and when i saw that it was like
a bomb went off and i could i could tell
by the details in their stories they
knew things that nobody else knew i knew
they were telling the truth
and there was this amazing moment of
liberation at i'm not crazy
all of the things the way this person
gaslit me anytime i questioned them any
time i
i challenged them the way they made me
feel like i was so wrong and i was i was
so unhinged
and then to and then to see that that
i was right like i can trust myself i
wasn't i i i see now the truth
[Music]